ايش عبد العزيز كيف الوضع حتى الموت باشن
اشكاله تكون له في بعض الاحيان رحم خصبه
تنبثق منها الحياه بابهى الوانها نحن
ننتظر الدور واحدا فيلو الاخر كتم صوت
الفلسطينيين او خنقه كان على الدوام هدفا
اسرائيليا ملحقا بحروب اقتلاعهم من ارض
وطنهم عليك ايها الفلسطيني ان تقبل بالنفي
بالمحو بالتشرد بالاهانه بالنزف بالموت من
دون ان ترى عين دم اطفالك يلطخ اقنعه
الحضاره او تسمع اذن نواح امك الثكلى بعد
ذبحك او يصغي قلب لحشرجه روحك تخرج من
جسدك ذلك ما ارادوه بل ذلك ما ارتكبوه
حرفيا على مدى ثمانيه عقود اغتيل غسان
كنفاني وماجد ابو شرار وحنا مقبل وناجي
العلي وشيرين ابو عاقل وعشرات اخرون سواهم
ممن حاولوا توثيق ماس النكبه وكشف جرائم
تتلال قبل ان يشهد العالم اخيرا ما يعتبره
كثيرون مذبحه اباده ممتده على الهواء
مباشره قتل فيها حتى الان نحو 50 صحفيا من
بين 100 الاف فلسطيني اودت بهم الحرب على
قطاع غزه خلال شهر واحد لم يكتفي الغزات
بانحياز الاعلام الغربي عبر تغييبه روايه
النكبه المستمره منذ 75 سنه وتبنيه روايه
التزييف التي ثبت كذبها
وبطلانها لذلك اطلقوا نارهم على كل من
يحاول كشف الظلم التاريخي الذي لحق بشعب
لا ذنب له في الظلم التاريخي الذي كان قد
لحق بهم قبل غزوهم لبلاده قالوا بصواريخ
طائراتهم وقذائف مدافعهم ان قصص موت
الفلسطينيين يجب ان تموت بموتهم او ان
تتوارى على الاقل خلف اصوات لا شيء يعلو
في حساباتها على اولويه التكفير عن عقده
الذنب الاوروبيه نحو اليهود لكن هؤلاء ومن
يناصر من مؤيدي مشروع الخنق المميت لاصوات
المضطهدين سيكتشفون للمره الالف ربما ان
الصاروخ الذي يقتل عائله صحفي فلسطيني او
يقتله هو نفسه يظل اعجز من ان يردعه شخصيا
او يخيف صحفيا اخر فيمنعه من تلقف
الميكروفون ليكمل المهمه الانسانيه
ما من مفر الا استمرار القيام بالواجب
وحمل هذه الرساله وبعد نحو خمسه عقود من
نجاح طلائع الصحفيين الفلسطينيين في نسج
اولى الصلات بين مخيمات اللاجئين التي
انتجتها النكبه واقلام الاعلام الغربي
التي طالما تجاهلت من قبل حقائق الصراع
سيتعرف الراي العام العالمي على شبان من
قطاع غزه يتصدون للتزييف
بامكانيات البسيطه وينشرون يوميات المذبحه
باللغات الحيه فيؤثر في الشارع الامريكي
والاوروبي فضلا عن العربي بشكل يربك
حسابات القتله ويسهم في فضح الاكاذيب معتز
عزايزه يستيا العقاد احمد حجازي انس
الشريف حمدان الدحدوح عبد الله العطار هند
خضري هي اسماء لبعض اصوات كثيره تعالت من
قطاع غزه وخرقت جدار الصمت الغربي فاستقبل
الشهر الاول من حرب ملايين المتابعين على
انستغرام وفيسبوك وتويتر في مختلف انحاء
المعموره لتكشف لهم حقيقه ما يحدث وتضع
امام اعينهم ساعه بساعه حجم الخراب الذي
صنعته اسرائيل على هذه البقعه من ارض
فلسطين عبود واحد من هؤلاء لا يتجاوز الس
16 ع من عمره وله من خفه الظل في تقديم
مادته الاخباريه عن ماسي الحرب ما جعله
يصير محل متابعه واسعه النطاق ينتظر الناس
اطلالته وان غاب يصيبهم القلق على مصيره
هو بخفه ظله ايضا يعرف على نفسه مازحا
بالقول انه اقوى صحفي في العالم وانه
الوريث الشرعي لشيرين ابو
عاقل هذا ماحدش يسرقه مني هذا الاستديو من
هنا بدانا ومن هنا
ننهي المهم احنا مش ننهي نحن بدايه
لنهايه